okay so here I am inside dev tools for
our page and I've got the div selected
that has our name and title it looks
like we're in the right place but let's
go ahead and check bootstraps
documentation to figure out which
classes we need I found this section
about alignment classes in the CSS
documentation it looks like we just need
to add text - right to get right aligned
text let's go ahead and try that out I'm
back in dev tools and I will double
click on the class to open it up I'll
type in text - right and press ENTER and
we see that our name and title
immediately pop to the right side of the
screen so it looks like we're on the
right track let's see if we can get it
capitalized right underneath alignment
we see transformation classes including
uppercase text all we need to do is add
the class text - upper case let's see if
it works so now we have text right and
text upper case and I'll press ENTER and
voila we have capitalized text that is
aligned on the right
so for right aligned text we just need
text - right and to make text uppercase
we simply add text - upper case it
worked for us when we added these
classes to class equals column medium
six but in fact you could also add it to
the h1 and h3 tags while adding it to h1
and h3 would work it's actually a lot
cleaner when you add it to the div
containing them